tell you something dude I would rather
yeah we're [ __ ] a red bandana in a
[ __ ] neighbor hahaha then go to a
[ __ ] cemetery I see two white people
with a boogie board and join in with it
I told you about the time I went to the
haunted hospital - yeah you're stupid
see that's the thing - like so edrick
has been wanting to go to this haunted
hospital it's it's it's in the LA area
and I'm pretty sure everybody has heard
about it its it's a was it a mental
asylum er wasn't a house so one they had
the main hospital and apparently they
had like kind of the psychiatric
psychiatric ward right yeah and so that
place is actually very very difficult to
get into number one if you do want to
get in there you know you can't anymore
even they tore down and turn into a
senior citizen community that's like so
they just put people on the verge of
death there cuz like if some of these
people have like dementia or some [ __ ]
or maybe they don't
I saw something as I go that's it it's
just crazy old Molly talking that
nonsense and yeah so they built the
scene so you actually got to experience
that place before it was yeah yes so
well prior to it being torn down it was
just very hard to get in there because
you had to have a film permit or
something from the city that allowed you
to be there yeah and and there was
actually a lot of security around there
and so he was trying to get him for a
long time and when you were telling this
story I remember you telling me that
Jeff was there because you actually
texted me - no John John oh yeah yeah
Jeff John yeah but somebody texted me
within the weather was Paul year or
somebody oh do you want to go I was like
no what are you [ __ ] to ask me that
[ __ ] delete this text I said I'll be
there immediately
this whole container butt-naked the
ghosts boners going you know was he with
the with you there Joe
he wasn't um so man that's a good man
initially nosy couldn't even because I
took him there before you know he
couldn't even look at the building from
across the street
he was like yo I'm getting [ __ ] bad
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] bro just look at
this smart man I'm looking at that [ __ ]
dude you know you can't you can't
acknowledge something you don't see and
you choose to ignore you don't meet a
crazy thought one of the times that I
was trying to like break in
there was a window that was open so I
had a homie give me a boost and then I
looked in and it was like pitch black in
there I couldn't see what where I was
landing into and I was like [ __ ] should
I jump in here and I was like no if I
get hurt though that might that might
kind of make this a bad night you know
so I I decided against it those are one
that was just one of the times I tried
to get it but when I actually got into
the hospital and I went to that area it
was a 15-foot drop
drop and then been stuck there in
pitch-black darkness dad dude maybe it
would have shattered your [ __ ] ankle
yeah you would have been one of the
spirits but yeah when I finally got in
there you know I was excited mad psycho
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] explore and
I'm gonna check this [ __ ] out and inside
there was a point in time when I did go
off by myself yeah and then just
everybody else was like he's got stupid
Oh
Oh Rick yeah so there were definitely
moments there where something was a
little off I was telling you guys when
we're doing the JK news [ __ ] like there
was a spot where it was ice [ __ ] cold
you know everywhere else's room
temperature in that room but it's just a
Randall it would be like here is ice
[ __ ] cold right I don't know how to
explain that it's just like I would
stick my arm out like this and then I
just get [ __ ] goosebumps because it's
so [ __ ] cold in that one zone and
then what does the big grab do you dude
I'd be like yes if you know these girls
don't even want you to thirsty dude well
you're not gonna get anything so the
only attack people I don't want that
[ __ ] yeah um and then I told you guys
the phone battery thing everybody's
battery was at like 75% or more and we
turn on our flashlights for maybe about
10 minutes right
within that 10 minutes everybody's
battery was down to like 5% you know and
they say spirits try to use electronic
devices to try to communicate I don't
know I don't know if there's any truth
to that but all I know is it was a
little bit weird that everybody's
battery got drained that quickly because
if we have the flashlights on for maybe
like 30 minutes maybe maybe then it's a
little bit more reasonable but 10
minutes to drain that much yeah and I
was telling you other people felt stuff
they heard stuff I tried yeah
I'm pretty [ __ ] up for this but I took
them into a hallway like other other
people came and I knew but both doors on
the hallway were locked shut right I
took him there and then I was like okay
this is the way out and then we went to
one of the doors and I tried to open and
it's like oh [ __ ]
yo this [ __ ] wasn't locked before I was
like hey I think there's an exit the
other way though let's go the other way
so we just do this long walk down the
dark hallway to the other oh [ __ ] dude
these are the only ways in and out
I think the [ __ ] stuff you're a
terrible person people started tripping
like yo yo what the [ __ ] how are we
gonna get out I'm like dude I don't know
man we might have to spend the night
here I was cracking up so hard we're
[ __ ] with the wrong things man yeah
what if what if a bad spirit comes at
you what do you mean I knew that I'm
ready for it you know what are you ready
for them what are you ready for what are
you gonna do nothing I'm just ready for
the experience is what I'm saying
whatever guy nobody to blame myself you
know hey you know I wouldn't be
traumatized you for the rest of my
[ __ ] life I would be traumatized man
but but even movies like the [ __ ]
ring dude oh yeah [ __ ] come on but
that's like you know grudge
any Asian version of like how they
interpret spirits and ghosts that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] creepy
you remembered you when we were [ __ ]
little and like our parents would watch
like some scary [ __ ] that [ __ ] used to
scare the [ __ ] out of me I'm like dude
what the [ __ ] man dude The Grudge yeah
that eyes me man
at what age though how old was I out was
still I was in high school when The
Grudge came out I think so I hated that
[ __ ] dude because here's the thing man
like when it comes to horror movies I'm
okay with horror movies with when it
deals with human beings so there's a
human being that's a psychopath whatever
guns talk the same talk Brett but at
Brett kill them all
you can't do that to a ghost no yeah
that's why dude I that's why I created
that sketch I ain't afraid no [ __ ]
ghost because I'm telling you right now
like straight up if ghosts let's say
ghosts do exist right and you end up
being like an evil whatever angry
Specter yeah well I'm not gonna be mad
at humankind if a ghost kill me yeah you
kill me I will [ __ ] you too no [ __ ]
and you have no [ __ ] clue I
it would be literally a vengeful spirit
going after spirits I would kill every
ghost out there dude ghosts would be
scared of me dude like this [ __ ]
is after us dear because you how [ __ ]
dare you I was chilling chilling and you
[ __ ] me up yeah I'm not the one that
wants you to come after him you go over
to this guy nothing I because they know
I'm a friend they know I'm ghost
friendly so I I encourage it I'm like
hey you guys wanna you guys need
somebody to talk to her you want
somebody to interact with I'm huge I'm
talking about Tim told me the story
where he met somebody either on a plane
or when he was travelling and he was
talking about this guy said that he was
so hyper connected to spirit and it
happened to him at a young age and as he
got older I guess like when he chose not
to just pay attention to these signs
they eventually his powers or whatever
eventually disappeared but when it was
very prevalent and he was paying
attention to it he said that he would be
driving listen he goes through a [ __ ]
tunnel or something
and a spirit would see him nobody else
sees it but the spirit would see him and
the spirit would look at him be like oh
you can see me mm-hmm
hey how's it going like let's talk and
he goes nope I'm gonna ignore this I'm
gonna ignore this and he would just
drive right by her but nobody would see
it but that would be like a spirit
whether it passed away in the tow or not
yeah but the spirit wouldn't recognize
him trying to have conversations with
them and that should creep me the [ __ ]
out and he goes well let's talk and I'm
like the [ __ ] no dude try to have a
conversation with UNH I'm trying to
[ __ ] deny your existence right now
let alone acknowledge you right now you
know it's a simple explanation for that
schizophrenia maybe but he says he
doesn't have it anymore
so he doesn't he doesn't have those
powers anymore because he ignored it for
so long like how do you [ __ ] even
like quantify that you know like oh I
got it I got a work on this power and
strengthen it or else I'm gonna lose it
you know like where the [ __ ] does that
even come from
dude I've Tim and I when we were doing
sin foods we did this thing where there
was like a psychic yeah you know you
know psychics talk to spirits and they
can see your future or whatever whatnot
this lady if psychics are real this look
this one was just full of [ __ ] it's
completely most of them and like her she
was she was so base
use the most basic psychic ever yeah I'm
talking about she might as well has just
been like the [ __ ] Jamaican lady on
the infamous Cleo tarot cards she um
like she would ask me Oh what do you
want in life
uh-huh and I would tell her what I want
in life and this you just mirror that
it's like do you're not even trying at
this point you're not even [ __ ]
trying and then she and I just remember
her because she had the most plaque I've
ever seen on teeth oh yeah like I could
have if I slapped her in her forehead
like a layer of plaque woulda came off
and she would have had an extra set of
teeth when you're not a crack it